This is funny cause I've been to fat camp twice in my life.
The first time I was 8 years old, turning 9.
I had my 9th birthday at fat camp.
And instead of cake like any normal 9 year old,
I had a watermelon with a lemon on top in the shape of a pig
and like a bunch of like nut and honey balls instead of cookies.
That was it. That was.
That was my ninth birthday.
I was nine years old,
I was in the mountains of Bulgaria,
and we were surviving off of basically a diet of fruits and tea.
And that was it for maybe three weeks.
I don't remember much of it the first time,
but the second time I did it, I was 16 years old, um,
and I did for about,
I don't know, three weeks. And I lost,
I don't know, 15 kg,
something like that.
So yeah, in that three weeks or so that I starved myself,
I definitely lost weight.
Right?
The second that I re entered society and I like, was a person again,
all that weight came back is like, it's not sustainable.
Like, the problem with dieting is not that it's like
you're not gonna lose weight.
Sure, you can lose weight.
The problem is most people will gain back what they lose and then some.
That's problem with yo yo dieting,
because like, whatever weight you start at,
the likelihood is that you're gonna gain All the weight that you lost
and then more,
so you're gonna end up at a higher weight than you started off with.
That's the problem with yo yo, dieting